みなさんこんにちはエブリデーに6というジーンズブランドの代表しておりますしまだ
俊介と申します
今日はよろしくお願いします
いけないですが皆さん神通何本くらいお持ちでしょうか
実は
jins
日本人の平均賞与本数は約4本だと言われています
ではどのぐらい年間で消費されているのかというと約1億本だと言われています
簡単に考えると1年に1人が1本新しいジーンズを買っているそんな計算になります
冒頭からいきなり事実な話ばかりですいません
あと10分ほど続きますのでぜひお付き合いください
では皆さん今日履かれている方もいらっしゃると思うんですがその神通
日本ではどこで作られているのかというと
ここです中国地方にある
岡山県の倉敷市児島というところで今から約50年前
1965年に初めて国産のジーンズが造られました
なぜこんな所で初めて作られたのか
話は江戸時代にまで遡ります
もともとこの小島というところは瀬戸内海に浮かぶ小さなひとつの島でした
しかし江戸時代末期に干拓押されこの本州と人を続きになるんです
当時は米作が非常に盛んで日本全国どこでもお米をたくさん作っていました
しかしこの干拓された土地では
塩害によってなかなかお米が育たないということでじゃあ何を栽培しようかという
ところで綿花の栽培がスタートするんです
それが後にこの小島というところが繊維産業
盛んになるルーツの一つになっています
そして
大正時代から昭和初期にかけては学生服の生産がスタートします
今は化学繊維で作っているものがほとんどなのですが当時は綿で作られることが多かっ
たです
学生服というのは非常に他の衣類に比べて厚手なのですごく縫うのが大変なのですが
この写真のように
近くの県から縫製工場に縫い子さんがどんどん集まってきた
という背景もありますこの厚手の生地を縫うのに慣れていたというのがこんな経緯も
あって
後に国内外の有名なブランドジーンズの有名なブランドの縫製をする工場がたくさん
集まるきっかけの一つとなります
しかし
このスライドをご覧下さい
1990年に国産比率50%あった
国産比率が
現在は3%それ以下まで減少しています
僕は実際に4年前に岡山に来たのですが僕が来てからもどんどん工場の数は激減して
おり今
現場を回っていてももうやめようかななんて声はよく聞きます
では一体なぜこのようなことになってしまったのでしょうか
それは現在よく言われているファストファッションの流行というだけでは語りきれない
アパレル業界の構造が大きく関係していました
まず1つは
モノを作っている工場と販売しているブランド
さらにはそれを購入するお客さんまでの距離がすごく遠いんです
実際僕たちは工場を見る機会は普段ないと思いますどこでどのように作られているのか
まったく知らない状況だと思いますそういったところがまず僕は課題の1つとしてある
んじゃないかとかん
られています
そして例えば今日この会場にお越しの皆さん
僕も含めてですがジンスを作って販売しようと考えたとします
まず
記事を仕入れないといけません記事を仕入れるために生地の向上そして
シルエットを作るためにパターンナーさんそしてそれを塗ってもらうための縫製工場
そして jins というのはだいたい一度洗いをかけてから市場に出るのが一般的
ですので洗い過去を施してくれる
工場最低でもそれらの向上を見つけないといけません
ではどうやって探しましょう
皆さんだとインターネットで検索する方が多いのではないかと思います
僕の最終はそうしました
しかしほとんどの向上はホームページを持っていないのでまったく
調べることができませんそしてかろうじてホームページを持っている工場を見つけたと
しても大きなブランドとしっかり組んでいるので運命な少数の生産し傀儡できない
ブランドは相手にしてもらえないことが多々あります
エイ
これぐらいアパレル業界はクローズなんです
僕がそもそもなぜこのようなことを考え始めたのかというと
もともとすごくジーンズが好きでした
でジーンズが好きでいろんなファッション雑誌を見ていたんですが
なんかとこのブランドの商品を見ても違いがわからなくて
今から考えてみるとジーンズというだけでまあほとんどが藍色なのでまぁその違いが
なくても当たり前なのかもしれませんが
まあ高校生の当時の僕は
誰がどこで作ってるかわからないからこれだけ違いがわからないのかそんな風に考え
ました
そしてたまたま大学進学で岡山に行くほどが決まりその岡山で僕は jins が好き
なんだということを色んな人に言っていると
工場見に行く機会を提供してもらいました
そして実際に工場に行ってみたんです僕はジーンズが好きだったので凄くかっこよく
見えました
このようにまあこれは過去を施している工場なのですがこのように1本1本手作業で
加工
ひげ方というのをつけて言っているんです
僕は目の前でそれを見て凄くかっこいいなと思ったと同時に
これを見るにはこの工場に行かないといけないのかと
インターネットで見ることはできない
ここに来ないと見ることができないのかということを
すごく悲しく思いました
そしてもっとこの情報を発信していきたいなということで
インターネット web メディアを立ち上げてこの工場を取材して情報を発信して
いこうと
いう動きをスタートしました
実際にいきなり工場に生産を依頼するとなると
ことはれるケースが多いのですが取材をさせてくださいというと意外と ok を
いただけるような工場もあって
取材はどんどん進んでいきました
そして僕のこの動き自体を地元のメディアにも取り上げていただき
より工場で働く職人の方々とお話しする機会が増えてきました
そしてそんな中で先ほども
観ていただいた数字これだけ工場の数
国内で作っている数が激減している理由は何なのかということを聞くことができるよう
になってきました
古城の方が口を揃えておっしゃっていたのはブランドから提案される高知に押しつぶさ
れ
納期を迫られ
利益が出ない状態で毎日を過ごしています
そして明日生きていくために今目の前の仕事をしないといけない
なのでこれから大きく方向転換するような考えもできないですし
新しい考えをくれるような若い人材を採用することもできない
こんな負のスパイラルに陥っていたのです
エイ
僕は1年間ほど取材を続けていたのでこの状況
何とか打破できないかと考えました
そしてある日記事向上と加工工場を訪れた時にふと思いました
これらの工場はブランドに提案するために
いくつかサンプルを作っているんです
そのサンプルは例えばブランドの亭主ととマッチしなければ捨てられているものが
ほとんどです
僕はこれはすごいもったいないことなんじゃないかなと
そのサンプルを実際のお客さんに見てもらって注文が入った分だけ作ればいいんじゃ
ないかと考えました
しかし少量生産なのであまり利益は出ない
だからオンラインだけで注文をとってあらゆるコストを削減してその生産ラインの中に
入れても問題ないくらいの利益をしっかり確保できるような状態でスタートしようと
いうことで取り組みをスタートしました
実際にクラウドファンディングを実施しへ
注文を取り始めたんです
イワナ背景を出して行って応援していただいたこともあって
目標金額の238%を達成し着地することができました
あこれを皮切りに僕は工場の方々とジンズの生産以外でもいろんな取り組みを一緒に
やっていこうということでブランドの立ち上げにいたり
ました
まだまだ未熟なところがあるんですが僕のこのような経験を踏まえて今日お伝えしたい
ことが3つあります
まず一つ
位置情報を取りに行こうということです
今の時代は
何か疑問に感じればインターネットで調べればある程度いろんなことはわかります
しかしこんな時代だからこそ現場に足を運んでその目の前の事に耳を傾けて
心で感じるということは自分だけにしか得られない情報を付加価値になってくるんでは
ないかと考えています
さらに地方にいるからこそその場所にいるからこそ生きやすいところ
そこにいるからそこにいないといけないような場所もあると思います
そういった面では自分が今どこにいて何をすることが有利に働くのかという観点で考え
て言ってもすごく面白いことなんじゃないかと思います
ます
そして2つ目です
良いものの定義を更新しようということです
昔ながらの古き置き点灯
よく聞くと思います
そのまま今の世代にも受けられ受け入れられていればいいのですが
なかなか若い世代に受け入れられずに縮小していっているような産業というのは
たくさんあると思います
そんな産業でも実はちょっと見方を変えれば見せ方を変えれば多くの人に受け入れ
られるそんな可能性を秘めているところも多くあります
そしてそれは
若いプレーヤーが少ない地方に多く眠っていて
より可能性を秘めていることが多いのではないかと思います
そういったところに先駆者として入っていって行動していくアクションを起こしていく
というのもすごくワクワクすることなんではないかと思います
そして3つ目です
好きだという感覚を剥い大事にする
まあいろんなことをやりたいことがあると思うんですがやはり好きなことをしている
ときが一番楽しいです
ただ昨今は僕も含めてですが sns を使われている方が非常に多いと思います
いい意味では個人の発信力が
ましたと言えるかもしれませんしかし一方ではフォローされフォローしている人や友達
の女を過剰に気にしているそんな側面もあるのではないかと思います
僕は自戒の意味も込めて改めて自分の好きなことを貫き通していきたいなと
を考えています
最後になりましたが僕の今日お話しさせていただいた
この経験が少しでも地域で動いている若い人
にプラスになればさらには改めて
思考を整理するきっかけになればいいなと思います
ご静聴ありがとうございました